good morning everybody and welcome to
development control b
um my name's kathy guthrie and i'm the
chairman today
first of all remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that you
maintain social distancing from all
other persons whilst in the chamber and
in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided please
ensure that microphones are turned off
when not in use
please do not interrupt the other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app and i do
apologize my computer is at home so i
will be giving my votes verbally
i would like to remind everybody present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except whether
our confidential or exempt items if you
make a representation to the meeting you
will be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to possible
use of those sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the alarm leave the building
immediately via the fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point ipswich
town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium ground floor area
and walkways
if you're in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit use the stairs not the
lifts and do not re-enter the building
until you are told it is safe to do so
so can we have the introductions please
indipre our legal adviser
gemma walker our area planning manager
robert carmichael the governance officer
case officers vincent pierce and michael
brooker over the back and we do have
alicia who's driving our live stream and
we also have um a trainee who's bethany
who's sitting at the back there so
that's all the people here
so can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies this
morning from councillor peter gould
thank you
to receive declarations of the cunery
and non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare
no
declarations of lobbying are there
anything to declare
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 27th of september
please
uh apologies jazz the meeting was only
two days ago i have not had a chance to
um write up the minutes from that point
i quite understand we'll do that at the
next meeting thank you it is on our list
all right
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received yeah
and we'll do the matters in the order
they appear so we'll start with
great bricette business park and i'll
invite vincent pierce to introduce the
application thank you
thank you chair good morning members
good morning guests as the chair says
first item
uh great brice business park in great
briset and what we're looking at is a
change of use of the land to site 69
mobile homes
this has been before your sister
committee previously where it was
deferred
and so what i'm going to do this morning
is take you through what we've
discovered and what we've negotiated
since that that meeting
essentially
previously we were asked to
get some additional details on parking
provision
to make sure that our floods and water
colleagues are happy with the proposal
to look again at landscaping on the
boundaries
and to provide members with details of
bus routes that serve great brice it and
that is in your report
we've also been asked to confirm the
number of units because there was some
confusion because some elements of the
application suggested there might be 73
park home units it is most definitely 69
and i have a layout to to demonstrate
that the other area that we've been and
looked at in more detail is securing an
affordable housing contribution which
wasn't previously available and i can
confirm that yesterday evening
we did receive a signed unilateral
undertaking from the applicant
in which he has committed to paying 168
000 pounds towards offside affordable
homes
the unilateral undertaking does
guarantee
the delivery of footwear improvements
and the bus shelter
it also includes open space within the
site and i'll go into more detail of
that as we go through but just to
familiarize the committee with the site
because you haven't seen it before there
it is in red at the moment a large part
of that site is covered by old nissan
hut style
industrial
buildings hence the term
business park
footpath runs around the southern and
eastern edge and the settlement boundary
sits there just to the the west
great price it sits to the northwest of
ipswich very close to watershed air base
on the screen you can see flashing in in
white an existing
park home
center known as wixfield
park
the site itself is accessed by a pound
hill and as you can see the airfield
sits very close to the the west where
the apache helicopters are based
there's an example of some of the nissan
hut style buildings that are at the back
of the site
so it is previously developed land what
we might have previously called
brownfield land
this is uh some examples from the
adjacent residential park wicksfield
itself
this is an important photograph insofar
as this is the entrance to wicksfield
park the adjacent site and the white
arrow shows where the
public footpath the footway starts that
takes you into autism this proposal
includes the provision of a footpath
from the application site linking it to
that
section of footway
a very quick
if we can
fly through what i need to do
is try and get this to activate
will it do it no
what i was going to do is take you on
the fly through but
seeing we can't there is the existing
holiday park this is the site in here
and over here sits the air base
sorry the airfield and this is plough
road coming up through here existing
dwellings in here
that's the settlement boundary
here is a plan that shows the 69
park homes sitting to the south of the
existing wicksfield park this
application is not submitted by the
company that operates wicksfield park
so
first batch 14 12 13 19 11
is a total of 69
homes and we're suggesting if members
are minded to grant permission we
restrict the maximum number to 69.
they are a range of two and
three-bedroom
units of different sizes and they're
shown in in the box in the corner
this is an example of the type of home
that will be provided here
in the event that members are minded to
grant planning permission
so i think in terms of the look of them
they are perhaps
i was going to say unusual that is i
think in my mind i had a picture of a
park home that
was something far less
elaborate and
potentially good looking than this and
that might just be my
naivety and ignorance about park homes
suffolk county councils the flood and
water authority are satisfied with this
proposal and they've suggested a number
of conditions that we are perfectly
happy to recommend to you in the event
that you're minded to grant planning
permission
so there is a drainage basin on this
site that will take all the
the water here's the existing bus stop
that sits at the top
right left hand corner and the dotted
line is the existing section of footway
what is proposed is to provide a new
section a footway and a new
bus shelter
so all the residents of this
development could safely access both
public transport and get into
watershed
this is a simply technical drawing of
the improvements to the footway the bus
shelter location is shown
circled in blue
question that came up last time is is it
possible to get from this site to bus
and
from bus by work and school and the
answer is
yes you can you can leave the site at
just before half past seven you can get
into ipswich by just before half past
eight and you can get to suffolk one
just before nine
you can get
home from suffolk one on bus
you can come back from work or shopping
in ipswich
the service would allow that
there's also a school bus that will get
you to stow market
high
and back and there are other routes that
get you to other locations so i think we
would say this is well connected by
public transport
the full details are in your reports
in terms of parking for each park home
a quick example here is
each
technically you have two spaces per
park home
in terms of the landscaping members
previously were concerned that because
this sits on the edge of open
countryside
the landscaping buffer wasn't robust
enough and that is a view that we shared
and we have gone away and the applicants
have agreed to
reinforce and enhance the landscaping on
the boundaries so if we take them in
turn
on that exposed
south eastern corner
we now have reinforced planting along
the entire eastern boundary and on the
southeastern boundary so in time this
site will be
completely
softened by mature planting
remember these are single story
structures so in no time at all that
tree and hedgerow will conceal them
let's go back one
on the road frontage we now have similar
hedge and tree planting to ensure that
the frontage from plow hill
is green rather than looking into a home
park
development
and again on the southern boundary here
we have reinforced planting on the park
side of the access road that road
already exists to serve the business
park
so as i say we do have the unilateral
undertaking that delivers contributions
for off-site affordable homes we do have
now a commitment to the footwear
connection and the bus shelter
we are recommending approval as we did
before but just to be sure we are
suggesting a number of extra
conditions as i say we would like to
restrict the number to 69
to avoid any confusion later
we would like to restrict it
the use of the site for park homes as
described and no other residential
building or structure
whilst permitted development may not
apply we want to be absolutely sure that
there's no doubt so we are suggesting a
condition that says for the avoidance of
doubt this development does not
enjoy the benefit of permitted
development
and the other conditions are asses
suggested by our colleagues in floods
and water
thank you chair
um thank you very much for that vincent
we obviously have the previous
notes of the previous
application and these are the additional
um reasons um i was pleased to see that
jude managed to get the 106 of 168 000
and does sil come into this as well
that's a very good
question and it's a it's something that
came up in the office on a similar site
and the answer is because people are
living here permanently it is a
residential park yes
still does apply in the normal way
subject to the same sorts of
conditions caveats and criteria
so yes
it does
thank you for that right sorry about
that uh gentlemen i interrupted uh
councillor stringer your question to the
player yes sorry i've got quite a number
i'm i'm really sorry uh
but it's important we get them answered
you said this was a brownfield site
uh i see a field with some what looks
like smart business units in one corner
of it are they
the definition of brownfield is normally
something that's then in disuse
so
is it actually is all of this field in
the brownfield definition
because i say from the aerial shot i see
a
green field with an element of
yeah define that's that one
of course
this council string it does count as
previously developed land all of that
site enjoys the benefit of
business use
we will ask
the guest our speaker to confirm which
units are
vacant
i'm not sure the latest position but i
also draw your attention to the fact
that there is an extent planning
permission for 51 residential units
on this site i didn't mention that in my
reporting to be fair i should have done
but it is in the previous report so in a
sense we already have a backstop
position of residential development
fine that would that would have been
really helpful next question
is this site allocated in the in the
joint local plan
but then the previous permission would
sort of trump that anyway i wanted to
ask about the
more importantly the sewage situation
normally the maximum amount of dwellings
of a
a disc plant off of a plant is normally
nine
this isn't attached to the main sewage
is it so normally you can the
manufacturers only allow nine per
treatment plant nine dwellings maximum
so how will this work with
60 odd in one treatment plant
because obviously we don't want to
approve something that then create a
problem elsewhere
i wanted to ask about
there's this sewage i've done that
done that one sorry stop you there
councillor i know can we do them one at
a time but just on the back it does um
well it is saying waste services but
that's not that's waste for the bins and
stuff
so could you give us a hand on that one
please
i have asked my colleague gemma just to
check the jlp to give us an update on
the latest position we'll report back
it is allocated as lso1 ls01 thank you
gemma
uh we haven't had any objections from
the relevant drainage
consorties
so
that's not the answer you were looking
for but in terms of
technical answer
it hasn't attracted
an objection
in terms of the
suggested conditions from our colleagues
at suffolk county in terms of surface
water i know you're talking about foul
water they're suggesting a condition to
secure the details technical details we
could do the same with foul
water
so that we would require a strategy for
surface and foul water that way we could
be absolutely sure that even though the
relevant drainage authority engine water
has not objected we would know exactly
how the
plant would be provided and operated to
ensure the problems you've suggested
might happen don't happen
excuse me interrupting could we perhaps
should matters move forward could we put
that as a an additional condition that
that is resolved
anyway but that's just a point for
debate i just wonder yeah if i might
just come back this is the problem
because this will only figure in the in
the in the assessment when it hits
building regulations
and of course we have huge problems with
this on other sites that operate like
this
uh where we do get sewage running in
public areas in these places because
there isn't sufficient provision and if
you if you
what you're being asked to
approve here is something that won't
work before you start
and a flooding authority won't pick up
on it it's your environmental health
team counseling
we can debate it and decide um as we go
forward the question would have been are
you satisfied that a planning condition
will
will be able to bring about something
that on paper at the moment we don't
have evidence that will work
i am because if the technical advice we
receive is it doesn't work they won't be
able to satisfy the condition so we
won't be able to discharge it
so what we would
expect we would word the condition where
it
would be recommended in such a way that
they could not proceed until the foul
drainage and the surface water drainage
strategy had been approved
and we knew what it was all about and
then we would require that strategy to
be implemented
and do you have further question council
stringer
i think that's it lovely thank you very
much counselor cast and then councillor
muller
thank you
um
so um
sill
i think i remember when we were first
bringing out sill
that we didn't charge still on them
a floor space under 100 meters squared
um and these although it is it's in feet
but i believe that most of these
if not all of them are under 100 meters
squared
um can you just clear that up for me
please
again i did ask this question
not so long ago of our infrastructure
team who are responsible for applying
civil charging and i asked them
specifically in terms of this type of
development of this size and their
answer was
it is liable now that's not the answer
necessarily you've asked me you've asked
me about 100 square meters but my answer
is they know this this application and
they have advised me that it is still
liable
i'm more than happy to go and give you
an update after this
meeting as to how that is but that is
their their answer
yeah okay
thanks
councilman
thank you chair vince can you just
please confirm what provision there is
for electrical charging points of
vehicles on this site please thank you
that is
a great question in safaris i haven't
got
details of electrical vehicle charging
and you're quite right we're treating
this as any other residential
development
and we would expect electric vehicle
charging
that can as we've done elsewhere be
secured by
condition and i think entirely
appropriately we should be asking
for it
so
i recognize that i haven't delivered on
that one but we can certainly
apply a condition where you might need
to grant permission that they do have to
you imagine that each of these has an
electric point getting to it so it ought
to be
relatively simple so yes a condition
would be
ideal
no i would accept that good question
counselor but what we can do is uh
confirm with the um applicants
agent that we can pursue that along the
lines that vincent has just said
councillor norris first then council
thank you uh my question
relates to emergency vehicle access
looking at the live plans
it doesn't appear
to me that there is any alternative
access other than the single access that
is shown
which is serving both wicksville park
and this proposed development
is there intended to be any provision
for emergency vehicle access
if we could go back to the presentation
please i might have
in my explanation i might not have been
as clear as
perhaps i should
so
in terms of this proposal
the access is here
which gives you access to this part of
the site
wixfield park
has its own access
yeah here
they are not connected but in terms of
emergency vehicles you would only expect
to access points where there is
more than 150
dwellings
and in terms of the layout of course
this is one of those interesting cases
where planning has a certain remit but
also
the licensing authority which is
mid-suffolk
also deals with the layout under the
caravans act
so they would have to also ensure that
emergency vehicles particularly fire
engines can get to every one of those
units
for the obvious reason of fire safety
so we are satisfied that this would
allow
accessed by emergency vehicles
and the number of units is low enough
not to require a second vehicular excess
fine as long as we're happy with that
thank you
thank you cheer
and thank you council
for bringing up the point about ev
charging points
um
i've got
i saw a few more questions really about
along the same line really this is a
substantial residential development of
69 homes
questions yeah i just need to
put a context as well
um
and with the developer we've been
normally expecting some sort of move
towards our um
its environmental impact was mitigated
so we'll be asking
questions about heating and cooling
resist resilience to um
extreme weather
uh compliance with building rags rain
water harvesting uh positioning of the
homes with regards to fitting the vv
cells
because this is um these are park hubs
does this put it
the development outside all of these
considerations
i think in terms of you as a planning
committee
you're perfectly entitled to
ask the applicant
and their agent
the extent to which they are looking to
meet your
green requirements
so i think we do have a speaker this
morning
i think it's the ideal opportunity to
ask
and if if you get an affirmative we can
then think about what conditions might
you want to add to
ensure that we get
some of that thank you
thank you any more questions for the
officer
no
right
we now move on to
public speakers
and we have the great bricette parish
council
david payne
i know there is another gentleman here
from
the other parish council but
um they have made a representation in
the papers we weren't asked
to have an extra speaker
and
i think members know that we often
have large applications and we don't
allow all parish councils to speak for
the three minutes so in this instance
we will just have the parish in which it
is entered
and that is david payne to speak on
behalf of the parish please thank you
very much
morning can you hear me
well i'm pleased you care because i'm of
a certain age nearly 80 and my hearing
isn't what it what it should be but i
try to follow what's being said
um i
um
the one thing that
uh concerns me is
buried in this dossier of papers there's
a statement by the applicant pointing
out
that the incidence or the
level of
park home provision within the whole of
mid-south up which is hundreds of square
miles is quite average nothing and
therefore this will make no difference
however
this application will double
100
the number of park homes in a village
which is designated as a hamlet
at the moment we have 70 park homes in
whitsfield park at a stroke if you give
permission that will double to 140.
now i'm not a planner but i do know that
in planning terms
uh park homes are not even
considered homes in the normal sense of
the legal meaning because they are in a
sense temporary and it's no coincidence
that park homes
have the lowest value
council tax band of a
and therefore that needs to be born in
mind that the people who move here are
downsizing and there won't be young
married couples
they will be elderly people so
the relevance of the local school is
somewhat um
not
a matter to be taken on board
also the parking is barely minimal in
fact there's a concession by the council
officers that
the applicant has made the parking
provision
uh to his advantage
so that he can get more units on there
that's that's actually the council
officer saying this even though they
don't object to it so bear that in mind
and we're worried because i live in this
same stretch of road that
the unintended consequences is that
who knows one parking place per unit but
we live in an age where even elderly
people sometimes have two cars and
where's that extra car going to go
on the street i suspect if if necessary
and it's a narrow street we don't want
any more problems there we already have
problems at the end of the road where i
live with the t-junction where the
original parking
proposals have proved inadequate on the
site eye level
um
the other uh my colleague from wrestle
is here and they
they i must reflect that their main
conclu is from their point of view they
get a lot of light pollution coming from
a park home site at night which they
will see more than we will
from the distance um
and that affects nature
and the well-being of living in the
countryside
uh there's no the buses that do run
there's three buses a day that run to
ipswich and there's another three other
bus routes that run in two days a week
to
uh to a stone market
so there is some
bus provision
the um
the
the doctor's surgeries are full capacity
at the moment
and
the
um
matter is
um somewhat
cons
worrying in respect of doctor's
provisions because i know for a fact for
myself how difficult it is to get an
appointment
uh
there
the um
the issue is do you i
is it
wise to
treat a hamlet to where they are 70
existing park homes and double that
overnight we've become and also an old
people's park home site rather than a
village and we're not even if we're a
hamlet mr payne you've had four minutes
actually could you continue to wind up
please that would be i will i think i've
said enough i'm open to questions thank
you very much
thank you um i've just made a couple of
notes and i'm sure members will indulge
me um
is
you say this is designated as a hamlet
is that in the new joint local plan well
i'm only going by the paperwork here it
says somewhere in here that it's yeah
that's reinforced by dan pratt who can't
be here today yeah he describes it
obviously he's
i think that's in the news it's in the
local play the new joint local plan
which is going through at the moment
right yeah yeah
i really should have asked the officer
if it's going
nitpicking to say whether it is or isn't
it it's going to be a hamlet hopefully
well we're waiting for our joint local
plan indeed um right members do you have
questions for mr um kane please
yes
no yeah thank you chair um just a
question on um local services um
in terms of people living in these park
homes um accessing a local shop or a pub
i
understand there's pretty much nothing
there now when the
when you go on the web on websites which
are
off
generally very out of date uh
you the shop that is mentioned on some
websites doesn't exist anymore it closed
about four years ago
uh
so there's no local shop that they'll
sometimes refer to in in this
application it doesn't exist
the nearest shop is down in parking i
would imagine
um
not barking need a market sorry the
co-op store down the bottom of barking
road
and
there were no enough no other facilities
the school there hasn't even got a
school there
there's a school nearest school is
ringshaw which you have to walk across
fields
uh or catch a bus to reach with a school
bus
but there's
so the facilities are few and far
between and as regards bus services
unfortunately suffolk county council
seems to have a penchant for
closing a road somewhere in north south
east or west every day by every time i
drive out around this area
and so the bus services that do exist
are frustrating the irony is that the
suffolk county council subsidised bus
routes i think you're going over the the
okay anyway
i get the gist of it and your
frustration is you drive currently and
and that's the the issue isn't it um any
further questions for mr payne anybody
no
um
we don't have an official objector but
if the gentleman who has come along
wants to word his words as an objector
rather than as a parish council can i
invite you along those lines and can you
introduce yourself please because you
did arrive rather late and we waited for
you and we started late so we didn't get
your name
um i'm chris payne i'm chairman of
ringshaw paris council
no you're correct we're brothers we're
brothers actually so it's just coming
i actually live in
um i live in ringshaw we
we think this
um application
far exceeds
the
levels of services that could be
provided for those that are
living in in the community um
as you know we have submit sorry the
parish has submitted um various
objections to
um the uh the plans one of them is
inaccurate statements in the original
planning application uh talking about
facilities that are non-existent
that are non-existent
um we also fear that there will be
roads and traffic impact
along in our area
and when your colleague the planning
officer
showed the aerial view of great price it
i would say 50 percent of that view is
actually in ringshaw because ringshaw
parish goes and goes into the air base
area so we do have a concern and we're
quite disappointed that we weren't
notified about this um application in in
detail
um
but we we the parish council did meet um
and the objections are basically as i've
outlined that the infrastructure and the
means impact
um will
uh
because of the inaccurate um uh
statements that have been made road and
traffic impact and also we're very
concerned about the visual and light
impact
if you stand there were some photographs
in the original
documentation which were taken during
the daytime and looking across to
where wicksfield park is but if you
stand in the same place at night time
there's literally a row of lights on the
horizon
going close to existing woodland
and
i hope if this application is approved
that there will be
considerable reflection on what sort of
lighting will be put into that site
so we think it's
basically too big for the area and i
always thought that great brice was a
hamlet we are basically side by side we
have a lot of common interests
with great brice and we see this is not
affordable
accommodation it's nothing like it it's
not open to young people it's
presumably middle-aged people upwards 50
years old
of age
the definition of affordable housing i
think needs to be looked at it's it's
just a ridiculous amount of uh
mobile homes in a very very small
confined area and i think the existing
the existing
um
park business park was a viable park but
i can see in one of the office's reports
that they're saying that um
it implies that it wasn't viable
originally but i understand that that
that was not the
uh the case it was a viable business
part but obviously the owners had other
intentions for that site
so i think i've said enough yeah
right on three minutes thank you does
anyone have any questions for the
objective as we are telling you good
self-canceller custom then counselor
stringer
thank you madam chairman um you said
it's not available for young people
um could you just clarify that for me
please i do actually think that actually
is stated in the documentation that the
applicants put in um in the early
documentation i really asked the
applicant that one rather than your good
self okay yeah and
sergey i have a question for the officer
that's arisen out of what is that okay
uh
the mindful of the
extant permission that could be
implemented and the fact the site
it appears in the
draft jlp
if this is approved will these dwellings
be part of our annual housing delivery
numbers
that is a good question and and i think
what i would
ask is perhaps gemma can contact our
policy
colleagues just to confirm rather than
me
say something that i'm
not sure on we'll go to the oracle and
find out
fine thanks very much indeed thank you
for that
um
counselor pratt can everybody else take
off their microphones please uh council
pratt can't be here did we get a
statement
oh i beg your pardon sorry yes indeed
i've jumped down here questions for the
agent yes we do have the agent would you
like to
have your three minutes please uh good
morning um richard buther from rps i'm
the agent um speaking on behalf of the
applicant
as the case officer has rightly pointed
out
and has emphasised in his report the
site the subject of this application
does
have the benefit of an extant outline
planning commission for residential
development for i believe it's 51
dwellings
the broader principle of residential
development on this site in relation to
access to local services and facilities
sustainability impact on the local
highway network and parking
drainage and the loss of employment has
therefore been established
the proposed mobile homes however have
several clear and distinct advantages
over traditional bricks and mortar
houses
the units can be cited serviced and
occupied much more quickly they require
limited ground works and the noise and
general disturbance during the
implementation and construction phase is
much less because a large proportion of
the construction work is carried is
undertaken off-site
this means significantly fewer journeys
for construction traffic which would
reduce the impact of construction on the
area
the type of mobile homes proposed adds
the variety of housing stock in any
given area and in particular the single
story bungalow accommodation is rarely
provided by volume house builders
lack of single story accommodation is a
major issue across the uk
meaning a reduced choice to those who
require or prefer this type of
accommodation which includes older
people or those with reduced mobility
the growth in this development is a type
of units beginning to address that
balance
with a lifespan of 70 plus years the
units require much less maintenance than
the traditional bricks and mortar house
many councils consider summer all of
this type of unit to meet the definition
of affordable housing
these units tend to be lower cost to the
buyer and an equivalent bricks and
mortar home and they allow buyers to
release equity and release their
existing homes back into the housing
market
while the mobile homes comply with the
nppf definition of affordable housing
we
are nevertheless making a proportionate
contribution towards off-site provision
additional affordable housing in the
area
an increase in the number of units on
this site above the extent permission
will improve the viability of the
services that do exist in the area
and as you'll see from the office's
report highways authority has raised no
objection to the additional numbers of
dwellings
and as the officer pointed out we've
addressed committee a's previous queries
about bus services landscaping and
drainage
so in closing the office has provided
you with a detailed analysis of the
issues relating to this site and
development and i'll trust you will be
able to follow his recommendation and
approve the application thank you
thank you for that and members i can see
councillor muller has a question for you
mr booker thank you
thank you very much
um yes can you please confirm what what
um electrical charging point should be
available on this site please
so um
if the uh it's not uh proposed across
the board but if that's something that
the um proposed occupiers uh like when
they're purchasing the units that can be
provided
if the committee is minded to make that
a blanket requirement that's something
we can take on board thank you very much
thank you
thank you councillor carsten
thank you madam chairman um the previous
question um
the comment um these houses are not
available for young people could you um
explain that yes i mean just by by their
very nature they do tend to appeal to
a certain demographic um the over 50 is
over 55s
but they're not necessarily going to be
exclusively available to that market but
by definition
those single-story accommodation does
tend to appeal and is tended to be
marketed towards that age range
so the
not available part of that isn't the
case
not necessarily
thank you thank you for that um any
further questions for the applicant
uh councillor
warboys please and then councilman
thank you thank you chair
uh i think you probably heard my
questions earlier really and it's um
i'm
and these are this is a substantial
development that's going to be there for
70 plus years
uh normally with a developer would be
asking what their
plans what the standards to which the
houses are being built with regards to
uh
heat efficiency insulation um how
they're going to be heated or cooled how
resilient they are to
um
climate change as summers are getting
hotter
um
could you actually just sort of sum it
up really rather than well so
we've already mentioned the uv charging
points i'm particularly interested in
what plans you've got for rainwater
harvesting
compliance with um meeting going towards
building rigs which don't apply in this
situation but
it's to do with it
insulation and are resilient they are to
climate change
um
[Music]
and and if i could have some information
about that
yes so as i said in my um statement um
that these units
are manufactured off-site they're
manufactured to the you know the highest
that there's many products on the market
but they um they are all manufactured to
the highest so possible environmental
standards
um in terms of sort of individual
[Music]
credentials in terms of rainwater
harvest again they are
issues that individual purchasers can
specify when they're ordering particular
products but again if there are
particular requirements that are called
with
the development plan they're things that
the
developer can take on board by whatever
condition
as these have
a temporary and they've got a limited
lifespan i mean what uh
arrangements have made for their
recycling or disposal afterwards
um they do tend to have a lifespan of
around about 70 years
[Music]
i think in 70 years time
the
requirements for disposing of these
sorts of sites we don't know what sort
of standards we'll be adhering to but um
i think uh they are
uh i think given that the materials that
they're constructed with i think there
are
fairly easy to recycle and dispose of in
environmentally friendly ways
in comparison with bricks and mortar
housing i would suggest
thank you for that um so was it
councillor mellon next
yeah yeah thank you chair um
just to slightly clarify that the
question um or the point that um i think
counselor caster was trying to draw out
the um
often with these sites
they can only be bought or sold through
the kind of management company that's
operating the site
and obviously restrictions like and over
over 50s only can be brought in there so
i wasn't sure if that's exactly going to
be a policy
for you
because you weren't really clear that
yes
as you say they they
they it will be marketed at the over 50s
over 55 the retirement market um but
as i understand at the moment there are
no um policies in place in terms of the
ongoing management of the site that
would restrict it to over 55 but it will
actively be marketed at that demographic
and and do these homes do they come onto
the open market or does it have to be
bought and sold through through the
management company uh they tend to be
sold through the management company but
access to that would be through the open
market
excuse me interrupting on that when i
just asked the legal person can we
actually put a condition in that says
that it should be open or or is the
applicant entitled to i know he's
entitled to advertise no i'm sorry you
can't speak um i know the applicant is
entitled to advertise how he so chooses
but i just wonder
on the the application as it's presented
and the officer's recommendation it's
not proposed there'll be any
condition or section 106 rest to do that
each and obviously if it were any member
suggested that there'd have to be some
kind of policy or
justifiable basis for that obviously if
that was suggested
on the floor of the committee
could you sit down please we have social
distancing and i'm sorry we can't have
great debates in the chamber sorry
thank you sorry i missed the last bit
yeah just to say madam chairman as i
think i think the committee's got the
point that there's no in your papers
there is the applicant is not suggesting
that um
as you say
if they wish to
advertise at a particular demographic
if that's the right word but that's
their choice because that's their
commercial market choice it's not
suggested in the papers you have either
by the applicant themselves or by the
officers making the recommendation that
there'd be any condition or section 106
obligation
restricting the age or other um
demographic of the
intended occupiers of these
units but if if it were to be suggested
that that should be the case there'd
need to be a justification
in exceptional in the planning room we'd
i'd want like i'm sure
mr pearson mrs walker could
give advice on that necessary so
basically you're saying steer clear of
that vince you wanted to speak and i was
really going to say that i think your
question was can you attach some sort of
restriction
technically you could but as mr duprey
has said you you would need the
justification
so if you are thinking that this
location is not ideal for children that
might be sufficient for you to suggest
that there should be an age
restriction on this site if you are so
minded if you wanted it the other way
you you wouldn't restrict it so the
answer to your question is yes
but it's whether or not the committee
is so minded i would actually like it to
be available to everyone
councillor stringer sorry i did try to
tell you to put your hand down that's
fine it's fine uh uh thank you chair uh
could uh
two questions uh they didn't come out
the early one how are these dwellings
going to be heated
because
if we're just to put you in the picture
if we're looking at bricks and mortar we
normally put implications on it no let's
just ask the question which is how are
they going to be heated and are these
properties mortgageable
uh i believe they are mortgageable and
they will be heated by gas or
underground lpg tanks
sorry and then coming back and then
after 2035 how will they be heated
i uh i don't know the answer to that
question i'm afraid
uh sorry uh i didn't quite catch the
last part of the heating yeah um gas or
underground lpg
uh tanks
right thank you uh but i have a question
which comes up about what we just said
about the age um
demographic that we're going to
uh what
do these um
park homes comply with accessibility
i think he's thinking of disabilities
for people to get yeah
yeah again they they're they're
manufactured off site to um uh
the specifications of the purchasers so
if there is a particular requirement for
a particular accessibility
needs then they can be incorporated into
the units that are put on the site
and they can be readily adapted as they
change ownership over time as well
thank you and vince did you have another
comment to make about the issues we were
talking about earlier or not um because
please i think we could almost debate it
yeah but i think i might be straining
into debate then um but
mr bootha said
gas or lpg
and i think the mood of the commuter the
feeling of the committee is with
the date looming where gas boilers are
no longer
allowed and with this development
probably taking a number of years to be
implemented were it to be approved
i think we do actually need something
from the applicant that sets out what
the strategy will be going forward in
terms of energy heating
uh the points that
yeah you are straight into debate i
think remember to bring that members
might want to think about conditions i'd
be quite happy to deal with that under
that heading
very helpful thank you very much indeed
right
so i think we really are now straying
into debate so who would like to start
the debate off
did you get a statement i do have an old
statement from councillor pratt which
which i believe is still relevant as we
haven't had anything new
um it refers that's fair enough um it's
um as we haven't received anything new i
would suggest that it's still the most
upstate and relevant in that regard
however i would just add that it does
relate to 73 prefabricated homes which
was what the one of the previous
references was when it came before
committee
however i don't believe that's a
significant change on voice i'll read it
out anyway and members can make their
judgment based upon that
um so the proposal to the site 73
pre-fabricated homes on great bricette
business park is unsustainable in this
location and the scheme does not
represent a low-cost form of housing
compatible with affordable housing as
claimed
there are not many homes that are both
affordable and available to young people
in great brisit
in the current proposal the new homes
would be available to only only to the
over 55s this excludes the younger
demographic and first time by first time
home buyers who are the most in need of
affordable housing the plan not only
fails to deliver effective housing
solutions for local people but compounds
the problems of living in the
countryside adding pressure to already
inadequate facilities
within the settlement hierarchy great
price it falls under the hamlet
classification
the class with the lowest allocation of
new housing
this is partly because it does not have
a shop the application erroneously
refers to the existence of the closed
spa shop
and other necessary facilities needed
for to accommodate larger growth
our emerging joint local planner
acknowledges that the location is
unsustainable for the large-scale
development such as this one
the nhs statement shows that the local
healthcare centres in bilderston and
needham market are running nearer or at
full capacity whilst the target age
group for the residential site is not
specified similar developments target
over 55s which should be taken into
consideration on the issue of local
services
should the committee consider approving
this application would they consider
applying a contribution to the provision
of additional health services in the
vicinity
to my best knowledge there has been
little if no support
for the scheme from the parish council
or wider community in great brighton
much of the objections stem from the
fact that the development scale and lack
of services to support it
but also poor accessibility
while suffolk county council highways
division does not feel that the
additional dwellings would add to the
congestion on the road this issue
remains a source of great concern to the
community
pound hill slash the street is fairly
narrow for two passing cars
the road opens into a nearby junction
with roman road
following a very sharp bend and has very
poor visibility of the oncoming traffic
turning into the street
to add to this hazard there are often
cars parked near to the junction
additionally new residents would be
mostly dependent on private transport
and there is an inadequate inadequate
provision of parking spaces
with one parking space per resident
there are concerns that the lack of
parking provision would result in
residents parking on the street which
would further compound issues relating
to road access
an additional concern is the road near
to the site entrance is frequently
flooded
every year residents report multiple
occasions of flooding on the highways
reporting tool the site has poor
drainage and the planning application
does not provide adequate detail on
surface water drainage systems
whilst the land may be considered as
brownfield the land brownfield land the
business park that was closed only in
2020 provided valuable employment space
whilst i am requesting that the planning
committee reject the planning
application i would like to suggest
the site be repurposed for a mix of
smaller scale residential and commercial
development
the village needs a small number of
affordable home
affordable housing that is inclusive to
all age groups and commercial space that
could contribute to the delivery of
public needs such as a shop community
allotments and green open space
make chair
yeah thank you well obviously things
have been superseded since then so
because vince did you not tell me there
are two parking spaces per
thing so that superseded still page 31
of the previous thing says that
contribution to the gps would be sought
to mitigate the impact so that's
superseded um but clearly
many of the issues members have sort of
queried it
and it is unusual to have an old
statement but it was pretty relevant but
i think it's the best that was available
madam chairman
exactly so
it would have been helpful to have just
had a wee bit of an update but most of
it did seem to have some content that
we've already inquired about
um so
there we are on that and we are now open
um to debate and i can see councillor
stringer itching to get going well i i
have yet another question i'm really
sorry but can we move on for the
officers well right yes it's important
that i understand i don't fully
understand this application and and this
question may help you
we've had some good debates so far
the answer should be
really simple uh it's about land
ownership uh and how it stacks up
the the only circumstance that you can
get a mortgage on a park home is when
the park homeowner owns the land that
sits underneath it
if it's leased you cannot get a mortgage
so therefore
this application does that seek to have
individual land ownerships for this as
as a normal housing estate or is it that
split model where there's two ownerships
and is that condition yeah if i may i
mean i think yeah council stringer is
quite right i mean a mortgage to a a
solicitor is is a a loan that's secured
on a legal interest in land so yes you
need you can have a obviously people
many people pure people in this room
than they have owned flats with
mortgages but then they have a legal
interest they have a long lease usually
a very long lease usually but um so yes
i i mean i i
i i
it's a long time since i did any
conveyancing i never did anything to do
with mobile homes so i don't know the
details of the mobile home finance but
yes i think i take cancer stringer's
point there must be a
illegal interest in land to charge with
a mortgage
so that was seeking clarification
because
traditional park homes you do not own
the land the agent said you'd be able to
get a mortgage therefore it must be the
second model where each landowner
has the individual land interest in each
individual plot and that's what i was
asking is what is that what we're being
asked to prove here so it'd be like a
normal house or is it the second model
where it's leased and you cannot get a
mortgage and can i ask a legal question
is that relevant to planning that we
should be deciding whether they can or
they can't get a mortgage
i mean the short answers is not not
really i think madam chair but i think i
think council of string is is making a
point if i may say so about the
the likely um outcome of if permission
is granted and that that's not
irrelevant um
i really don't it's a bit irregular do
you want to invite if if no one in the
room strongly objects do you want to
invite the agent to add anything to what
he's already said i'd stop to even let
him share but only if he's got something
substantial rather than
imagine
advise us properly no is the
planning lawyer rightly pointed out it's
not strictly speaking a planning matter
and i i don't have any great expertise
in that and that matter if um
if there is those that understand these
these models better than i do um
feel otherwise i'm happy to attract that
statement that they are mortgageable
thank you
thank you right so um did you want to
continue with the debate councillor
stringer as you're on a roll well we
can't go into debate yet because the
pivotal question i want the answer to i
haven't got the answer will these count
in our housing delivery numbers
that is the question that we're
trying to get an answer for but
i'm literally just um waiting for a
reply from robert hobbs so hopefully
we'll get something on that very shortly
right to the answer for one question i
think we should start the debate because
i'm sure that won't be final critical
issue councillor castle
thank you madam chairman um
i think these kind of houses really do
have an important place
um they're obviously where older people
can release capital
and
live in a smaller more efficient
size house
there's some really good um community in
these places the people that
socialize and they get um
and they um they do a lot of things
together
i've actually visited
the um
most of these sites
like um
for when i was a volunteer for the
ambulance service
they're really intensively
high um
high cool areas um because of the age
the the the people
there tend to be older there's some
we were backwards and forwards to those
some
sites quite a lot the um
it sort of brings me on to a bit of this
application that i'm just
struggling with a little bit the um
we're looking at a brownfield site so a
discount in sil
we we are charging still but it's a
discounted sell
homes that are easily adapted to be
elderly accommodation which is no sill
please stop me if um they can't be
adapted like that but short of a ramp
that would be no still on the site we've
got not enough health care provision
in the area to cover this site and we're
looking to deal with that with a sill
payment
also we've got a site the
ambulances from stone market would have
to go right around the base
to get to so
healthcare provision on the site is like
a big worry to me i'd like i'd like to
know whether
i'm not right and saying that these
houses can it seems to me like if
somebody
orders one of these
houses they can order it with a ramp
with complete disabled um
um
everything for disabled access um
everything to make it an elderly
accommodation and then be um
be
sill-free
on that um
if that's true please um
let me know or if i've got that wrong
but um it
this this is a problem there isn't
enough healthcare provision for the
people in these
in these houses and they will need a lot
of it they're very they're very high
risk people
so um
so
in favor of this type of development and
what it brings and how it frees up large
family homes but this particular one i'm
i'm really concerned that there's not
the provision in place
thank you for that was it councillor
muller did you have your hand up i can't
remember i'm losing the plot i'm sorry
your comment being you shouldn't really
be entering the debate but
it was just a question raised by
councillor casten that i think i can
answer if it's a question
fact
whether or not sil is applicable in this
particular case and as i say our
colleagues say it is but if it isn't sil
is a pool of money that is available
across the district
and therefore the ccg can draw down
funds from our pot from the cell pot in
the normal way to provide additional
health care
any
anyone can draw down
for that purpose across the district so
whilst this may provide no or a little
or a large amount of sill
the part is much much bigger and the ccg
can draw down from that depending on
need
yes
i wonder here whether paragraph 120
subparagraph
c of the national policy planning
framework gives substantial weight to
the value of using suitable brownfield
land within settlements for homes and
other identified needs and support
appropriate opportunities to remediate
the spoiled degraded derrick
contaminated or unstable land we've been
told this is part of brownfield site so
that would probably apply
secondly i am concerned about the ev the
actual electrical vehicle charging
points and if the committee were moved
to approve this application i would
certainly like to see a condition
added
into that if that is possible please
that's fine but we have to remember that
this site has an extant position
permission extent i can't say commission
one of them um yes
um gemma sorry i've got hands going on
no that's fine thank you i just have had
the response from um from robert hobbs
if i can come in please i think that
would be helpful thank you yeah so he
has confirmed we don't count it in our
housing land supply numbers
the housing and planning act does uh
recognize mobile homes as having a role
in contributing to the supply of housing
so if it's for the 51 dwellings with the
consent it would be in the amr whereas
the 73 mobile homes sorry 69
would not be included in the number
hopefully that answers that query
does that help councillor
yes good now who else had their hand up
before councillor stringer i think i
think
councillor norris go for it
thank you
i know
the area very well and i do not believe
the local infrastructure can
accommodate this proposed development
there's a limited bus service the local
shop is closed the nearest goal in the
ringshaw is not easily acceptable on
foot
due to lack of continuous footpath
development will be very car dependent
adding to increased traffic movements on
narrower roads
for these reasons i cannot support this
applications i do believe that is
sustainable in the true sense of the
word and would be over development
considering the lack of local facilities
thank you
thank you councillors councillor warboys
thank you chair um
i i've got concerns about the impact on
the local infrastructure in particular
as councillor caxon mentioned that the
accessibility
of
healthcare
and i would like to say i'm not averse
to non-traditional methods of
construction i'm not averse to
homes being built in factories i am
aware
that they can be built to really high
standard in terms of insulation
heat efficiency
and and so on and and be re and in terms
of recyclability um
but
i i am i would like to see what
conditions we can attach to this
um
in particular uh the ongoing strategy
for heating and cooling
i i think this sort of
underground propane gas heating i think
is really contrary to what we're trying
to do
as a district council in
working towards net zero
i think we do need some conditions
attached with regards to lighting to
reduce the impact on that in the
environment and
and the biodiversity
um
i i also think that you yeah it is this
is a very substantial
development i think we need to look at
sort of
how as a developer
what conditions we can attach with
regards to
um rainwater harvesting in terms of sort
of flushing toilets and which would
could be done as a
on a communal scale rather than as an
individual
property
i think it is a bit
i'm thinking on a larger scale than
rainwater but
rather than
you know some substantial reservoir for
storing water and making it available to
the units for flushing toilets and
whatever
um
[Music]
so i i think that's my point i'm
i think this development needs
this proposal needs developing in order
to make it for me to make it sort of
really something i could support
thank you
just on your few comments there it does
say on page 26 lighting and design
scheme wildlife and it also says
biodiversity so there are things moving
forward in your
line of vision on that
um
but i just make that comment
um thank you for bringing those points
up um who else would like to speak
answer stringer thank you yeah thank you
chair uh sorry to be uh pedantically
about the answer to the question about
the the housing need but that for me is
absolutely critical in my determination
of this application i would i would
straight refuse this application it's
going to do nothing to deliver the
housing identified in any of our plans
or count towards the housing number if
we've now got a deficit in our
housing delivery number we're going to
have to provide them somewhere else or
we're going to be in deficit of our
housing delivery number we then lose our
five-year land supply it's absolutely
critical there's a perfectly good extent
permission here to build houses
houses that will deliver for everyone in
our community
uh and a housing number up to 35 of 50
homes would deliver 15 homes at least
that are genuinely affordable for
everyone in our society not just people
that are downsizing uh on a property
they they can't get a mortgage on
i i see absolutely no reason there is no
benefit to anyone to provide
doubling the amount of these kind of
homes in this area and it will put our
own plans in deficit so frankly i i have
no hesitation in refusing this
application because it's totally
unsustainable
thank you any further comments
counselor melon
yeah thank you chair um
my parents live in one of these park
homes not not on on this adjacent site
but elsewhere and um i'm actually quite
in favor of them they're they're they're
warm they're fairly efficient
um they can be built well off-site and
and brought on site and uh
you can obviously
do things like collecting rainwater in
your water but
perhaps not on the scale that uh
councillor warboys is talking about um
but then when you start to look at this
site i i really struggle with it a
little bit in terms of um it being a
sustainable location i totally realize
we've got an extent permission here
um but if we were looking at this as a
greenfield site we'd be really having
some big question marks over it
in terms of local services shops
things that people could
walk to
primarily because a lot of the older
people who live on these sort of sites
don't drive
you know i feel much more happy about
this if if the um
the operators of the site had provided a
little on-site shop where people could
get their supplies
um
so
it's a bit of a mixed bag really and
then when you start to add in things
like the fact that they're going to be
using gas to heat them
uh rather than looking a bit more
forward direction it does raise quite a
few question marks to me
um but i'm happy to hear what other
people have to say thank you well i
think most people have said that bit
haven't they
it's only me i mean i i have
listened to many of the issues that
people have some of them i take on board
and agree with them
the previous permission i just wonder
why it was never built out
and i could just ask when does that
extent permission run out
do we know
if you give me my material just quickly
again
[Applause]
check on the planning history
and just while you're looking for that i
mean i too like councillor mallon look
at these um some of these park
properties and they do look very smart
and
very appropriate for that type of living
um
so shame is a bit
bit of the arguments about being
restrictive let's sort of leave that to
one side
they do seem very nice
homes and that's what people need is
homes
6th of january 2022.
so in the new year
uh so
here we are
does anybody want to make a proposal
about anything or whatever so that we
can move the debate forward because
we've got to go one way or the other
councillors
yes
just to make that clear that is when the
time for reserved matters expires
ah so it would if they were submitted
before 6th of january 2022 there would
be another two years after that that's
the deadline for submission of reserve
matters it wasn't outlined and that was
for
51
dwellings as such
and so these are different applicants on
the site
right
okay so councillor stringer i think you
put your hand up didn't you no just to
help debate really uh i
i would
propose moving refusal on this because i
believe this to be in our own policies
development there has been no case made
that their park home site is needed
within this area this has been
designated and has approval for general
needs housing
that would promote sustainability
because there would be a mixture of
tenure mixture of sizes uh and something
that would
would help every member of society
and we've allocated this in our plans
for housing
to
to approve
something that's
you know mobile in it any
mobile home type park home is is is not
within our policy they should be done on
an exception basis when approved when a
need has been established the need for
these has not been established here what
the but the need for general housing has
been and the knock-on consequence of not
delivering the houses
in our supply numbers by not developing
this site as we've planned
will cause a burden elsewhere more
greenfield will have to be developed
elsewhere if this is approved in this
form
that we refuse this application
unsustainable development
that this is required for general needs
housing as per our
joint local plan submission
council norris
yes thank you
i am happy to
second the proposal for refusal of this
application
i think uh councillor stringer has put
very well all the silent points so i
won't add anything further thank you
if anybody wants to speak to the motion
i would just make a comment that
if we build houses as such how does it
become more sustainable
for the
doctors the
footpaths the bus services and so on i
just find that a little bit of in
conflict and counselor casting
for me that we we talked about the sill
money um this to me is a a sink for
money
for sil money for health care provision
we should be if we were creating houses
they would be paying for a lot more
provision than um these are i think um
i think the sustainability side of
things i think council strings got a
really good
point with that it's um it does seem
that this type of assault of sight
is
for a certain type of person and we
don't have that provision we um with
houses you get a far more mixed group of
people that are able to travel to the
shops able to um they
perhaps don't need as much healthcare or
as intensive um
healthcare so um
for me yeah i think sustainability is a
massive issue
on this site because
it's mobile homes because it's um
because of the um the resident that it's
aimed at
um anybody else wished
gemma yeah
thank you it was just to come back i
think we might need to develop the
reason a little further on slight
concerns obviously we have allowed 51
houses here
i assume i might ask vince to come in
here on the basis of its location we
have accepted that this is a sustainable
location so we've got to consider that
as a material consideration
um and i would also perhaps invite the
policy basis on which we're looking at
and also caution weight on the jlp
obviously we haven't we're not in a
position where we can give that weight i
absolutely appreciate the concern going
forward about our numbers but at the
moment that's not an adopted policy that
we've got to use unfortunately thank you
thank you well that was my doubts when i
said we've already
you know
how does it become more sustainable or
less sustainable when we've already
allowed it um so um would you like to
give the policy to um gemma that you
wish to amplify on that
well
the policy comes from the definition
these are not houses these are not
dwellings because we're not counting
them in we're not allowed to count them
in our number so it has fundamentally
changed
and and all of the things that flow from
sustainable development suddenly become
unsustainable
as dwellings they're available to anyone
that wishes to mortgage them or those
that can't because some of the element
will be genuinely affordable
okay
up to 35 would be genuinely affordable
on this site yeah but you've made those
points yeah but i'm asking you to help
gemma to put what the council can defend
on
the policies
that you know that's that's what she's
just asked you for it is very difficult
because these are no longer houses
the the fact of the matter is if
everything let gemma just respond
because we really need to sort of bottom
this out yeah i just want to go back so
i was just rereading uh what robert
hobbs had said so he just doesn't count
to us land supply numbers but the
housing and planning act 2016 recognizes
mobile homes as having a role in
contributing to the supply of housing so
we've got to give that a balance of it
they are saying it does contribute to
the housing albeit i see your point it's
somewhat different but
it's that really difficult line
unfortunately
and and in the mppf assessment of
such parks it says where there has been
a need demonstrated and there has not
been a need demonstrated here for this
type of development which is by
definition restrictive in its tenure
you cannot get a mortgage on these the
reason there's normally restrictions you
can't impose a negative restriction on a
permission but that's where the problem
comes in in the imbalance in
sustainability so are you asking gemma
to put in there because they can't get a
mortgage this is one of your reasons is
that what you're asking us to put in
because they're unmortgageable it's an
unsustained if all of our housing stock
converted to this
type of tenure
we would be quite a lot in suffolk going
on these basis
but can you give gemma the meat on the
bones not just your passion which i hear
and i i applaud
but you know
will this stack up
um
with what we've got so far gemma
as a
refusal i have to admit i'm struggling
with that because i'm not coming up with
a policy on which this is contrary to
well
it comes down to if if there is not a
policy
that doesn't allow a developer to
restrict
it to build something that's
unmortgageable
to only targeted a certain section of
society by policy
then then there needs to be a policy
that does happen i thought the policy
was in the mppf that park home should
only be there if a need had been
demonstrated
yes
can you but because it is accepted by
the mppf that general needs housing and
the affordable housing within that
contributes to a sustainable society
because you have every strata of society
there you have children you have the
elderly you have the possibility of
people helping each other counselor
counsellor i
accept your passion but we've got to put
it into words that is defensible
that gemma is struggling with you on
this i i mean i don't make the policies
we sat on the policy team maybe we
should have popped a policy in about it
that could hang our hats on but i hear
very clearly what you're saying and i
understand the passion of it i really do
mullet because we must move the debate
forward but if gemma can't
come up with something then we've got a
very weak
um
reason councilman i fully appreciate
counter stringer's passion on this but i
personally am really struggling myself
to come up with a refusal on this i
think the sticking point for me that
planning permission has really been
granted 51 properties i think you want a
very very sticky wicket chair very
sticky wicket yeah because if we're
using unsustainability it's on that but
i again hear what counselor custom was
saying well and your good self counselor
stringer that if we have properties we'd
get more sill we'd get more this that
and the other but there's a sill part
that we can all draw it's a real
conundrum and it's it's very valid
points that are all being brought up
but i you know we've got to think of the
council and what we're here to do
is to
come up with the right decision and i i
know
that sometimes is a conflict with one
another
all i ask is gemma if you've got
i don't know i've never come across this
i need a legal piece of advice is if the
planning officer can't come up with a
reasonable
resolution what do we do with the uh
what what do we do with the situation
obviously it's for the committee to make
its decision we officers give advice the
committee makes a decision it's not a as
as he's very well known in this room i
don't need to say
that's a democracy obviously but um i i
think
that the committee must obviously be
mindful of the
um the any and reasons for refusal
need to have a proper basis under
planning i don't know is it would this
be one of those cases where we withdraw
for um
we look at the uh what's the word i'm
looking for you can help me on this it
happens on other cases
if we overturn an officer's decision
there have been i think it's more common
in other districts in suffolk and
possibly but there have been instances
um
as you know i also work for west suffolk
council and they have a
protocol that you don't have here where
there is an adjournment for a risk
assessment
the brainstorm that i had that i
couldn't think
would members feel more comfortable i'm
throwing this into the pot not usurping
uh councillor stringers and and
councillor norris's proposals would it
be better if we have a risk assessment
withdrawal
that we're minded to
refuse but dealing with a risk
assessment
possibility madam chairman of the
committee wishes
and would counsellor stringer have to
withdraw his
proposal and we re reword it on those
lines and it's obviously counsellors
stringer and his second as prerogative
to say yes or no to that indeed
do you gel what we're trying to say is
that
we need to we maybe need to do a risk
assessment you know as well as i do if
we overturn officers recommendations
is something we could consider would you
we would do that relatively regularly
in terms of
i mean we have the officers having
difficulty in finding a really strong
case it's a real difficulty because
we've already got an extant position
which says it is sustainable yeah yeah
but the problem that we've got that in
the eyes of the government in approving
this we then get rid of the delivery
that we approved in the first
what your place are i'm trying to get a
resolution
that will come up with a sensible
outcome for the council for the people
sitting here
and for us as judges as it were
i'm what i would suggest through you
chair is were you minded to ask for a
risk assessment it would allow us to get
chapter and verse from our policy
colleagues and actually ask them to be
party to the
report and actually come before you next
time with their view
that sounds quite sensible because for
me it being par or not being part of the
housing delivery was critical
and that's where i was trying to come
from and that just sinks it so on that
basis we can word it a little bit better
but and we'd leave you to do that if you
wish councillor stringer but would you
withdraw your current
proposal on this basis and we'll reword
it on the basis that this report was
written without that knowledge i'm
prepared to withdraw and counselor
norris would you be happy as seconded to
do that at this point
i'll go along with the suggestion of the
risk assessment yes right so counselor
stringer do you want to put it um how
is it that we are minded to refuse
yeah
subject to risk assessment of the of the
policy framework
does that help absolutely thank you yeah
so my note at the moment is uh the
committee minded to refuse subject to a
risk assessment as the proposal fails
deliver housing with an appropriate mix
of tenure and size was that the and meet
the i think it was and meet the um
yeah yeah she she did say size and
mickey yeah yeah yeah
do you want to read it out clearly and
then you will ask councillor norris if
he would be happy to second that you
want to read it again thank you so
committee minded to refuse subject to a
risk assessment as the proposal fails to
deliver housing with an appropriate
mixture of tenure and sizes uh with
particular regards to the impact as a
result of the neighbouring properties
does that capture
the concerns
yeah yeah i think so i think so
yes council of nice seconds
so on that basis at the moment we are
deferring it so um
thank you everybody for the input on
that
sorry chair um about that
delay there so just to confirm that the
vote will read that application dc 2005
587 be deferred and minded to refuse for
the reasons as read out by the area
planning manager is that acceptable
to the proposal
if you want the word
i was happy with what general had read
out yeah
just to be clear the the full wording
that gemma has read out will be put in
the minutes it's not it's just for the
vote that's in modern.gov so that
i think i think we're all aware of the
reasons
okay if that's acceptable then i will
now
start the vote on that so the vote is
now in progress chair can i take your
vote
thank you
apologies members it hasn't started
there so if members could please go to
the plus sign in the top right hand
corner of today's agenda and go to the
plus sign
sorry go on the subsection on attempted
slash voting and the vote will be shown
in a light blue color
thank you chair that is a unanimous vote
for the proposal for money to refuse
thank you and can i just remind people
that this matter will come back to
committee again it may come back to a or
it may come back to b
because previously this one went to a
and so you know you
it may come back to alb it just depends
how it sits and also if members wish or
members of the public wish to speak
could you please make your uh
representations um
i might not be the chair on that one and
um
if two parish councils wish to speak i
think it has to be exceptional rules
but could you sort of make sure that
well in advance when it's notified that
you make the appropriate requests okay
thank you very much everybody for your
attendance do you want a 10-minute break
and then we'll start straight away after
that
moving swiftly on yes
welcome back everybody and let's proceed
with the uh second case dc 210458
and we'll invite the case officer
michael booker to introduce the
application please if you would michael
thank you
thank you good morning members okay so
this is application dc2104458
uh one rectory road in wyverston
the application is for the construction
of a drop curb and vehicle are hard
standing for the benefit of a registered
disabled person um the application comes
to committee as it's been made by
mid-southwest on mituffago and land
okay so this is the site in context um
the address addresses are marked by the
star there and
um
it just gives some uh context
between bacton and long thurlow
and this is an arrow view of the site
um yes of a mix of dwelling types along
a straight road of 30 miles an hour
and it just uh just zoomed out a little
bit um again fairly straight road in a
linear residential development
okay so this is the site location um the
hard standing is outlined in red there
and just uh
not really many constraints in the area
there are a few listed buildings um to
the west but not to be affected by uh
the drop curve
and uh the site lies within the uh built
up area boundary
okay and again just a slight layout of
the area
um so a visibility display was submitted
which gives
visibility to the center line of the
road
highways weren't happy with this and did
request a visibility display to the
nearside edge
and just a close-up of that
general layout
so as you can see
there is a vegetation along the uh front
boundary frontage
which is to be removed as part of the
proposal
um
the
access is uh for over three meters in
width and at 2.4 meters back um again it
gives clear visibility to the center of
the road
with the potential visibility of two by
two meters as um illustrated in dma3
standard drawing
um however highways did request that is
the visible display is drawn to the
nearside edge rather than the center
line
so an alternative display was submitted
however i probably can't see on this one
but
um the visibility does cross the
neighboring boundary ever so slightly
um did you just amplify the ever so
slightly in centimeters or whatever okay
so on uh this is the uh kind of zoomed
in version
um
yeah as you can see on the right hand
side the visibility blade crosses by
things of about 20 centimeters
and on the left hand side it's by about
28 centimeters
um
[Music]
uh
the highways officers did comment that
because this is an area of low uh low
traffic that they will be willing to
accept a
um lower standard of two meters from the
from the carriage rather than 2.4
but this is the team meter drawing which
does cross by that 20 to 28 centimeters
um
and there is
some general pictures of the site um
yeah that's the
dwelling there with no current access
and all that
planting is to be removed
um that's the um
let's see the neighboring access
um
so as you can see it'll be sort of like
this kind of area here just just cuts
across where it would um
cut across the neighbor
um actually every act every house along
this road has
an access um
some of which are far below the standard
than what we
are seeing under this application
um and you know there's the sign context
with the the neighboring house
um
so although it is
marginally below the standards um we
have gone for a recommendation of
approval because given the site in this
context this is probably the best that
can be done
um
and uh taking time into the context that
it's a 30 mile an hour road it's a wide
road and low low vehicle traffic with
i think there's no been no recorded
incidents from for the last 22 years
along this road
it's not going to create an unacceptable
impact
uh in accordance with paragraph 111 of
the mppf
thank you
um did they send did the highways send a
further you were going to
i think there was a lake paper wasn't
there yes that was the um the comments
that were in the late papers yesterday
for which they still held a
it was a holding objection yes i did say
holding rejection but gentlemen please
quote me wrong that whilst they say
holding ejection still they can't issue
holding in the same either yeah it's not
quite the same holding objection as sort
of the environment agency or natural
england might be able to put in it's
their way of saying we'd like more
information
so from my understanding we had the plan
to the centre line they had a holding
objection they asked for it to the
nearside edge we got it to the nearside
edge at 2.4 meters back but that stood
that clip to neighboring land they've
said two meters that was their request
that came in tuesday wednesday this week
we've got that plan it does still
marginally clip the neighboring
properties but it's that marginal amount
whether that would be an unacceptable
impact bear in mind we do still have a
clear line of sight to the center line
the carriageway in a 30 zone with a lot
of
access is already onto that road so it's
somewhere where you might expect cars to
be maneuvering and um
also
it is in use as an access at the moment
although it shouldn't be in that
potential enforcement issue but if they
if we enforce they would be parked on
the road so it's that balance of what is
unacceptable harm and our conclusion is
that it's not to a level that's
unacceptable i appreciate often we
recommend members and say yeah they
don't achieve the vis play
but i think they are there are
particular circumstances in this case
that we think that marginal difference
and the fact that they do still achieve
it to the center line would be why we
contend to recommend approval i hope
that explains further chair
yeah and just one further question it is
for a disabled person isn't it
uh yes yeah okay thank you
right
thank you very much sorry i've
interrupted again anybody else have any
further questions for the planning
officer i think we've done
very enough does anybody want to open
the debate for me please
oh are you oh i beg your pardon you
should be over there
thank you pardon carry on
no
um just to say very briefly i'm very
happy to support this application um as
we saw from the slides the the access is
in in fact in use
um
and this um
arrangement we have in front of us i
think only improves the situation so i'm
very happy to support it
right anybody want to start the debate
counselor muller sorry
in view that there's no um opposition
from the war member i would actually
just to move approval on this one and we
grant planning permission thank you
thank you very much for that do i have a
secondary councillor stringer happy to
send that jay
speak to the motion no
in that case then i think we can go to
the vote if we may be pleased
thank you chair
vote is now in progress and we'll be
showing you in members modern.gov apps
and counselor can i take your vote yes
our support
thank you very much chair members and
public will note that councilman will
not be voting as is the um
procedure for um mid-suffolk board
members so just a note there
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that's the unanimous vote
for the proposal thank you
thank you very much indeed do we
have any site visit proposals
non-requested chair in that case thank
you very much everybody the meetings now
close thank you
you